tenant advocates are calling today for
the community to help families affected
by the pandemic they want leaders to
address evictions before the national
moratorium
expires at the end of this year hector
mejia has the story
well the group says they've heard
concerning stories of landlords trying
to go around the cdc moratorium
and intimidating tenants the
organization arriba las vegas
wants people to know that resources are
available they say
more help is needed especially for
immigrant workers
who are not eligible for unemployment
benefits
they estimate the number of people
facing imminent evictions
is in the thousands here in the valley
one of them is enrique gonzalez who has
not been able to return to work full
time as the only income earner in his
family
he says it's been extremely difficult to
pay the bills
since the moratorium here in las vegas
has ended
landlords feel like they have a green
light
that they can start using abusive
tactics to get tenants out
some of our members are resorting to
living in garages
living in their cars it is affecting
black and brown people low-income people
disproportionately
we are in a public safety crisis right
now they are struggling to inform people
about their rights
they describe this as a humanitarian
crisis
happening in our own backyard the
organization also believes a new wave of
economic hardship and homelessness could
plague the city
once the national moratorium expires on
december 31st
reporting near downtown hector mejia 8
news now